5.3 codex, or I guess 5.4 codex now. And then, you know, Sonnet and opus. And whenever you do that, one of them always solves it. And so that's where I'm at. What is your, you know, daily workflow? We know you're on cursor. What's your, what's your model that you use? I use the, the Claude 4.6 opus high thinking. I use like the slowest, like, best thing. because I don't care how long it takes. I want it to be as good as possible. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 277 recorded on March 10th, 2006.
5.3 codex，或者我现在猜是 5.4 codex。然后，你知道，Sonnet 和 Opus。无论你什么时候这样做，它们中总有一个能解决问题。这就是我目前的状况。你的日常工作流程是什么？我们知道你在用 Cursor。你用的是什么模型？我用的是 Claude 4.6 Opus 高级思维模式。我用的是那种最慢、最好的模型，因为我不在乎需要多长时间。我希望它尽可能好。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 277 期，录制于 2006 年 3 月 10 日。
My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we revisit the topic of AI and do a deep dive the first time since August of 2025. Sorry, I was, I was distracted by the AI. I was too busy talking to it to notice you were back. Understandable. Understandable. I got Auto Run working. Maybe.
我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们重温 AI 这个话题，这是自 2025 年 8 月以来的首次深入探讨。抱歉，我刚才走神了，被 AI 分心了。我太忙于和它交谈，没注意到你回来了。可以理解，可以理解。我让自动运行（Auto Run）跑起来了。也许吧。
I don't actually know because it still asks me quite a lot. So there's a couple weird things with the new auto run. First of all, the old auto, like the old or the sorry, the non-auter run mode, if it needed to search the. We're talking about cursor, folks, just we're hopping right into it. We're going to talk about AI, lots of stuff today. but Bryce was telling me I needed to focus all my energy on getting sandbox, auto run with cursor, 2.2. Whatever and higher. I'm on 2.6. And I finally, thanks to, well, actually, let's get their names, just their first names. Thanks to, why isn't Slack open? Slack's not open? Because we got issues
我其实不确定，因为它还是经常问我。新的自动运行功能有一些奇怪的地方。首先，旧的自动运行，或者说抱歉，非自动运行模式，如果它需要搜索……伙计们，我们在聊 Cursor，我们直接切入正题。我们今天要聊 AI，还有很多东西。但 Bryce 告诉我，我需要把所有精力都集中在让沙盒自动运行在 Cursor 2.2 或更高版本上。我用的是 2.6。我终于，多亏了——好吧，其实，让我们提一下他们的名字，只提名字就行。多亏了……为什么 Slack 没打开？Slack 没开吗？因为我们遇到了问题。
with my computer folks, and I had to restart it. Was that the root cause the problem? No, no, no. I just, I thought I'm having SSD issues, but I asked Kerr, cursor about it. It said that my SSD is fine. It ran some F-Trim command, and that freed up 76 gigabytes of stuff, and it said you don't have F-Trim running. And so I auto-set that up, but every once in a while I run into an issue where I lock my computer screen, and then just like the UI becomes awfully slow. Like, you know, I will type in a character, and then I'll see it like a minute later show up. And so I just have to restart. And I thought it was an SSD issue. Curser seems to think my SSD is fine. Anyways, thanks. Shout out to Pavo and Scott on the CDD Code Assistant cursor thread in our Slack. The main cursor individual just pointed me at the docs. I'd already seen the docs, folks. And also was telling me that my colonel wasn't new enough, which it definitely was. It was. But yeah, yeah. Well, I don't know. It is confusing. Dot 11 versus dot 2, you know, Which is newer? Is it, is dot 1-1?
我的电脑出了点问题，伙计们，我不得不重启它。那是问题的根源吗？不，不，不。我只是以为我的 SSD 有问题，但我问了 Cursor。它说我的 SSD 没问题。它运行了一些 F-Trim 命令，释放了 76 GB 的空间，并说我没有运行 F-Trim。所以我自动设置了它，但偶尔我会遇到一个问题，就是当我锁定电脑屏幕时，UI 变得非常慢。比如，你知道，我输入一个字符，一分钟后才显示出来。所以我只能重启。我以为是 SSD 的问题，但 Cursor 似乎认为我的 SSD 没问题。总之，感谢 Slack 频道 CDD Code Assistant Cursor 线程里的 Pavo 和 Scott。主要的 Cursor 开发人员直接让我去看文档。伙计们，我已经看过文档了。而且他还告诉我我的内核不够新，但它绝对是新的。确实是。但，是的，是的。好吧，我不知道。这很令人困惑。点 11 和点 2，你知道，哪个更新？是点 1-1 吗？
You know, technically that's, what do you call that? They call that lexicographically less than two. But if you interpret it as a two-digit number, then it is larger. Anyways, I got, thanks to these two individuals at Nvidia, I got the sandbox auto-run working. However, at first I thought it was working great because it wasn't asking me for stuff, but now it still asks me to run like Python commands every once in a while. And I'm like, that should definitely be inside the sandbox, you know, rules. So my experience with it has been interesting because it used to be that the way our cursor was set up, you know, if it wanted to search the internet for something, it would just do that. But then any command that it would need to run, it would ask for permission, which was like super annoying because my job just became sitting there and waiting two minutes for it to churn out the command and then pressing yes. And then inevitably I would go do something else and I would come back like 30 minutes or an hour later and remember it. And I'd be like, oh, this thing has just been waiting for my.
你知道，从技术上讲，那叫什么？他们称之为字典序小于 2。但如果你把它理解为一个两位数，那么它就更大。总之，多亏了 Nvidia 的这两位，我让沙盒自动运行工作了。然而，起初我以为它运行得很好，因为它不再问我东西了，但现在它偶尔还是会让我运行一些 Python 命令。我觉得这绝对应该在沙盒规则之内，你知道。所以我的体验很有趣，因为以前 Cursor 的设置方式是，如果它想搜索互联网，它就会直接去做。但之后它需要运行的任何命令，它都会请求许可，这超级烦人，因为我的工作变成了坐在那儿等两分钟让它生成命令，然后按“是”。然后我不可避免地会去做别的事，30 分钟或一小时后回来才想起来。我会想，哦，这东西一直在这儿等我的。
approval. But now what I find happens is that it'll run most stuff in the sandbox. The way that it works is basically it tries to run everything in the sandbox. And if it doesn't have enough permissions in the sandbox, then it will ask you to run it outside of the sandbox. But what I've noticed is that with the sandbox mode enabled, I get these requests to like fetch content from the web. And I don't think it's like downloading scripts. It's like, oh, like I want to look at the docs for this thing. So I think if you have it in sandbox mode that like any network request, it's going to ask for permission. So that is annoying me a little bit that like I don't mind approving the commands that actually do need approval. But like basically if you if if you're encountering that, you should look at the reasoning trace.
批准。但现在我发现，它会把大多数东西都在沙盒里运行。它的工作方式基本上是尝试在沙盒中运行所有东西。如果它在沙盒中没有足够的权限，那么它会要求你在沙盒外运行。但我注意到，在开启沙盒模式后，我会收到一些请求，比如从网络获取内容。我不认为它是在下载脚本。它就像是，哦，我想查看这个东西的文档。所以我认为如果你处于沙盒模式，任何网络请求它都会请求许可。这让我有点烦，我不介意批准那些确实需要批准的命令，但基本上，如果你遇到了这种情况，你应该查看推理轨迹。
It probably means that the Python commands that's running in the sandbox for whatever reason don't have the right permissions. sometimes that happens if like if it needs to access something that's outside of the repo route so just like look at the reasoning trace it should like explain it like you should see you should see in the reasoning trace like the reason why it didn't like why it failed to run it in the sandbox but has it been a force multiplier for you yet not really not really i mean don't get me wrong cursor itself is a hundred X force multiplier but the auto run like until it i don't have to click
这可能意味着它在沙盒中运行的 Python 命令由于某种原因没有正确的权限。有时如果它需要访问 repo 根目录之外的东西，就会发生这种情况。所以只要看看推理轨迹，它应该会解释原因，你应该能在推理轨迹中看到它为什么在沙盒中运行失败。但它对你来说是倍增器了吗？还没有，真的没有。别误会，Cursor 本身是一个 100 倍的倍增器，但自动运行功能，直到我不需要点击。
any buttons. Like, I don't care whether it's like 10% of some set of stuff or 50% of some other set. If it's any percentage of any set of stuff, that is like in the common path, a.k.a. Network requests, aka running scripts locally, aka, I mean, I think you should still be able to locally remove files if you're in a Git repo. You know, you can just, you know, get checkout dash, dash, dot, and you're back to where you were. I mean, removing stuff outside of the repo. Yeah, that should require, because, you're in a get, you know, because. that is something every once in a while now. And this is one of the great, we should back up in a second and start giving a full AI update.
任何按钮。我不在乎它是某组东西的 10% 还是另一组的 50%。如果它是任何一组东西的任何百分比，也就是在常规路径中，比如网络请求，比如在本地运行脚本，比如，我认为如果你在 Git 仓库中，你应该仍然能够本地删除文件。你知道，你可以直接用 git checkout -- .，然后你就回到原来的状态了。我的意思是，删除仓库之外的东西。是的，那应该需要权限，因为你在 git 中。这是我现在偶尔会遇到的情况。这是伟大的事情之一，我们应该退后一步，开始提供完整的 AI 更新。
Because I entitled last episode, The Mini Cursor slash AI Update. But anyways, we'll step back in a second and do that. We'll talk about the models we're using our. I'm trying to get statistics right now about how much more code I'm output in with the auto run than before. I was scared of the auto run for a long time. You know, like we're like old men basically in the world of AI. because we're still using cursor, you know, like we're not using ClaudeCode like everyone else.
因为我把上一集命名为“迷你 Cursor/AI 更新”。但总之，我们稍后会退后一步做这件事。我们会谈论我们正在使用的模型。我正在尝试获取统计数据，看看使用自动运行后我输出的代码比以前多了多少。我长期以来一直害怕自动运行。你知道，我们基本上是 AI 世界里的老头子，因为我们还在用 Cursor，你知道，我们不像其他人那样使用 ClaudeCode。
No, no, no, that's not true. First of all, I'm not an old man. You're an old man. I was, I bootstrapped an auto-run OCR screen capture. Like, I was working with a project where I really needed, I like didn't, I needed it to be running while I was away. And I, and we didn't have access to like what they called Yolo mode at the time. So I wrote, I got, I bootstrapped using cursor.
不，不，不，那不是真的。首先，我不是老头子。你是老头子。我引导了一个自动运行的 OCR 屏幕捕获。我当时在一个项目中，我真的需要它，我需要它在我离开时运行。我们当时没有权限使用他们所谓的 Yolo 模式。所以我写了一个，我引导了它，使用了 Cursor。
I think it was 3.5 at the time. A script that would take script. screenshots of my main monitor, it would identify the, I think there was like three different things. One was run, one was approved, and it changes over time. It would find that. Then it would use auto hotkey, I believe, or some, you know, Python move your mouse module to move the most, go click the button. Beautiful, beautiful. You're, I'm not old man. And someone, I actually told someone this like way back, like a year plus ago. And they were like, well, aren't you worried it's going to like, you know, RM dash RF, your system? And I was like, that is a risk I am willing to take because of how
我想当时是 3.5。一个脚本，它会截取我主显示器的屏幕截图，它会识别，我想有三种不同的东西。一个是运行，一个是批准，它会随时间变化。它会找到那个。然后它会使用 AutoHotkey，我相信，或者一些 Python 鼠标移动模块来移动鼠标，去点击按钮。太美了，太美了。你，我不是老头子。有人，我实际上在一年多前告诉过某人这件事。他们说，你不担心它会 rm -rf 你的系统吗？我说，考虑到这些工具的有用性，这是一个我愿意承担的风险。
useful these tools are. And it never did, folks. It never did. So you may be an old man. Does it make us old? You said you tried cloud code, yet you're back to cursor. So what happened? So, okay, no, no, no. I didn't try cloud code. I downloaded cloud code. I tried to use our corporate login to log into cloud code. And because, like, with it, I couldn't get cursor auto run working similar to you. I followed all the instructions, but, like, I wasn't showing up. And so I was like, all right, I'll just try clog code instead. I actually didn't. I think actually, I didn't know that we had cursor auto run. I just knew about the ClaudeCode auto run. And so I was trying to download and install Claude code with like our corporate, you know, account. And when I tried to do like the single
它从来没发生过，伙计们。它从来没发生过。所以你可能是个老头子。这让我们变老了吗？你说你试过 ClaudeCode，但你又回到了 Cursor。发生了什么？好吧，不，不，不。我没试过 ClaudeCode。我下载了 ClaudeCode。我尝试使用我们的公司登录名登录 ClaudeCode。因为，我无法像你一样让 Cursor 自动运行工作。我按照所有说明操作了，但它没显示出来。所以我当时想，好吧，我还是试下 ClaudeCode 吧。我其实没有。我想其实我不知道我们有 Cursor 自动运行。我只知道 ClaudeCode 的自动运行。所以我尝试用我们的公司账户下载并安装 ClaudeCode。当我尝试进行单点登录时。
sign on through Claude, like it gave me an error and I went to the Slack channel and like five other people had reported the error. So I just determined like Claude codes, you know, SSL, like SSO integration with us was not working that morning. But like I had to do stuff. So then I like search within the internet. And I was like, oh, there is a cursor auto run. I don't have to go learn any new things. Also, my, like, my first, like, two minutes interact, because cloud code is a two-y. It's a text user interface. You start it from the command line, and it pops up, like, a little text windowing system instead of just being a GUI. And my initial interactions with it solely from starting it to, like, the first few steps of the login process, I was like, oh,
通过 Claude 登录时，它给了我一个错误，我去了 Slack 频道，有五个人报告了同样的错误。所以我断定 ClaudeCode 的 SSO 集成那天早上对我们不起作用。但我必须做些事情。所以我上网搜索了一下。我当时想，哦，有一个 Cursor 自动运行。我不需要去学习任何新东西。而且，我最初与它的两分钟互动，因为 ClaudeCode 是一个 TUI，文本用户界面。你从命令行启动它，它会弹出一个小的文本窗口系统，而不是 GUI。我从启动它到登录过程的前几步的最初互动，我当时想，哦，
this is so awkward. And, like, I keep in mind, I'm somebody for many years, Like did everything in VAM and like a command line. I never used an IDE before AI whatsoever. But like my initial reaction with this was like, ugh, you. Like I want to go back to cursor. And I feel like I'm going to give it another shot probably after GTC because everyone seems to be using it. And somebody made the point to me that because there's so many people using it, that there's a ton of like useful skills out there for Claude Code.
这太尴尬了。而且，请记住，我多年来一直是在 VIM 和命令行中做所有事情的人。在 AI 出现之前，我从未使用过 IDE。但我最初的反应是，呃，你。我想回到 Cursor。我觉得在 GTC 之后我可能会再试一次，因为每个人似乎都在用它。有人向我指出，因为有这么多人使用它，所以关于 ClaudeCode 有很多有用的技能。
And that like you're like one of the one of the benefits using it is that you get like ecosystem effect of like everybody else using it. But I'm very happy with the cursor experience generally. I like having an IDE for this type of development because I find that the majority, the thing that I spend the majority of my time doing is not writing code. If I was just writing code, I would probably, you know, want to do that in VIM, but the thing I'm spending the majority of my time doing is browsing through the code base, you know, browsing through the structure of the code base, looking for particular files or something to give it a task to do, reviewing code. And I think if I'm spending most of my time reviewing code or browsing through
而且使用它的好处之一是你获得了每个人都在使用它的生态系统效应。但我对 Cursor 的体验总体上非常满意。我喜欢为这种开发配备一个 IDE，因为我发现我大部分时间做的事情不是写代码。如果我只是写代码，我可能会想在 VIM 中做，但我大部分时间都在浏览代码库，浏览代码库的结构，寻找特定的文件或给它分配任务，审查代码。我认为如果我大部分时间都在审查代码或浏览文件结构，我想要一个 IDE。我想要一个 GUI。不仅仅是文本界面。所以我再试一次，看看会怎么样。是的，我们应该把这两个都列入我们的待办事项清单。诚然，我试过 Cursor CLI，我认为它的模型非常接近 ClaudeCode。我听说过关于 ClaudeCode 的一点是，每当你提出请求时，它会问你几个问题，比如“你想让我用 React 还是 Flutter？”之类的。对于 Cursor CLI 的体验，我当时想，这比 Cursor 差多了，我直接回到了 Cursor。没有冒犯的意思。
the sort of the file structure, I want an ID. I want a GUI for that. Not just solely a text interface. So I'll give it another shot and we'll see, we'll see what it's like. Yeah, we should put it both on our list of things to do. Admittedly, I've tried cursor CLI, which I think is modeled very closely after Cloud Code. And I have heard this about Cloud Code is that anytime you make a request, it like gives you a couple questions like, do you want me to use React or Flutter? or like something like that. And like the cursor CLY experience, I was like, this sucks compared to Cursor and I just went straight back to Cursor. No offense.
我的意思是，Michael Truel，Ennisphere 的 CEO，你们做得很好。我只是说 Cursor CLI 的体验比 Cursor 差。我一直觉得我没有切换的必要。然而，我却在这里抱怨我们基本上没有 100% 的自动运行。但我不认为你在 Claude 那里也会有。比如，公司自动运行，我想，好吧，我知道他们有一个试点项目。我不知道我们是否被允许谈论它或谈论任何这些，但我知道他们正在努力推出带有网络访问的自动运行。所以就像沙盒，但带有一点网络访问权限，带有允许列表。
I mean, the lovely folks, Michael Truel, CEO of Ennisphere and you're doing great work. I'm just saying the CERL CLA experience was subpar compared to Cursor. And I just have had, I mean, I'm saying I have no need to switch. Yet here I am whining about the fact that we don't have auto run basically like 100%. But I don't think you won't have that with Claude, either. Like, like, the corporate auto run, I think, well, I do know that they have like a pilot program. I don't know if we're allowed to talk about it or talk about any of this, but I know that they're working on rolling out auto run with network access. So like sandbox, but with some amount of network
我看到过几封关于那件事的邮件。所以我们可能很快就能做到。它在沙盒模式下的工作方式是，所有这些沙盒模式，它们使用内置的操作系统或内核功能来运行你的东西。我不想说它像 Docker，但它有点类似于容器化，像 Docker，它在你的操作系统上运行，但在一个单独的环境中。我认为在 Linux 上，Cursor 和 ClaudeCode 使用的东西叫 Landlock。与 Docker 的区别在于，Docker 在不同的环境中运行它。
access with like an allow list. I've seen a couple emails about that. So we may be able to do that soon. The way that it works in like sandbox mode. So all these sandbox modes, they use like built in OS or kernel features to run your stuff in. I don't want to say it's like Docker, but it's kind of like similar to like a containerization like Docker where it's running it like on your OS but like in a separate environment. I think on Linux, the thing that like cursor and cloud code use is called Landlock. The difference with Docker is that like Docker runs it in like a different environment.
它就像 Docker 的沙盒，但在不同的环境中。我认为 ClaudeCode 和 Cursor 在进行沙盒处理时所做的是，它不是一个不同的环境。它是你相同的环境，但它仍然是沙盒化的。所以它有一套不同的权限，并且它对你的文件系统、网络有隔离的访问权限。所以当它在你的仓库中运行时，它会给你仓库内的文件访问权限，但它没有整个文件系统的访问权限。是的。我认为它叫 Landlock。但是，你知道，我认为带有网络允许列表的自动运行的想法是，默认情况下，今天如果你尝试在沙盒中访问任何东西，任何需要访问互联网的东西，它在自动运行中都不会工作，然后它会失败，然后它会请求你的许可。有了允许列表，它会给你一组被批准的东西。Nvidia 特有的另一件事是，我认为在 Cursor 和 ClaudeCode 中，默认的沙盒设置没有 GPU 访问权限。所以如果你需要运行你的测试，因为你在 Nvidia 工作，你的测试正在测试……那只是我们业务的一小部分，对吧？GPU。等待 Bryce 脸上出现笑话的反应真是太搞笑了。我能看到
And like it's like Docker's like sandbox, but it's in a different environment. I think the thing that Claude Code and cursor are doing when they're sandboxing is it's not a different environment. It's your same environment, but it's still like sandboxed. So it has a different set of permissions, and it's got like, isolated access to your file system, to your networks. So like when it runs it in your repo, it's going to give it access to the files that are within your repo, but not like the whole, it doesn't have access to like the whole rest of the file system. Yeah. I think it's called Landlock is the thing that they, that they use. But, you know, like, I think the,
齿轮在转动。现在还是清晨。Bryce 当时想，等等，他在谈论 GPU 吗？所以这只是 GPU 开发和容器化中的一个常见问题，你需要一些权限来访问 GPU。我认为在这些工具中，默认情况下，沙盒环境没有 GPU 访问权限。所以每当你去运行任务时，它都必须请求许可。我注意到我最近大部分工作所在的仓库里有一些预提交钩子（pre-commit hooks）。预提交钩子不在沙盒中运行。但我其实挺喜欢这样的，因为我会让 Cursor 为我写提交信息。
idea with the auto run with a network allow list is like by default right now today if you try to access anything in the sandbox like anything that has to you know access the internet it's like it won't work in auto run and then it'll fail and then it'll ask you for permission and with the allow list it's like it gives you a blessed set of a blessed set of things and one of the other things that's specific to invidia is that i think in in both cursor and claud code. The default sandbox setup does not have GPU access. So if you need to like run your tests and your, because you work at Nvidia, your tests are testing. That's only a small part of our business though, right? The GPUs. Waiting for the joke to register on Bryce's face there was hilarious. I could see
我会告诉它，比如，提交这个更改，推送到 GitHub，打开一个 GitHub PR 等等，因为我不想处理 Git 命令行。但我注意到，有时如果我告诉它，嘿，去修复这个东西，有时它会去修复它，然后它会问我是否要提交更改。有时它会直接提交更改。它会在我有机会审查它之前就这么做。所以预提交钩子在沙盒中失败实际上是有用的，因为这意味着在它提交任何东西之前，它会去问我。是的，有一次，不是在我的工作站上，而是在我的工作笔记本上，我不知怎么地神奇地，在大约一个月的时间里，我下载了一些 Cursor，
the gears turning. It's it's rather early in the morning right now. And Bryce was like, wait, is he talking about the GPUs? So this is just like a common problem with GPU development and containerization is that like you need, you need some amount of privileges to access the GPU. And I think by default in these tools, the sandbox environment doesn't have access to the GPUs. And so anytime you go to run your tasks, it has to ask for permission. Like, I've noticed that I have some pre-commit hooks in the repo that I've been doing most of my work on recently. And the pre-commit hooks don't run in the sandbox. But I actually kind of like that because I will have cursor write my commit messages.
它刚好有 Yolo 模式。我当时非常担心 Cursor 会在某个时候强迫我更新。但那是在 Claude 3.5 的时候。所以这就像，你赢了一些，输了一些，对吧？我们现在真正需要的是 4.5 Opus，像 3.5 Sonnet。它没那么好，但仍然，不用按那个按钮真是太棒了。除了有一次它确实为我写了提交信息并推送了。我当时想，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。我当时有点害怕。我当时想，我没让你那样做。我不知道为什么你认为我想让你那样做。所以我立刻把它加到了自定义规则里，或者不管它们叫什么，并说，请永远不要
for me. I'll tell it like, you know, commit this change, like push it to GitHub, like open up a GitHub PR, et cetera, because I don't want to deal with the Git command line. But I have noticed that sometimes if I tell it like, hey, go like fix this thing, sometimes it will like go fix the thing and then it will ask me if it wants to commit the change. And sometimes it will just commit the change. And it will do that before I've had a chance to review it. So it is actually useful that the, that the pre-commit hook fails in the sandbox because then it means that before it commits anything, it goes and asks me. Yeah, at one point on, not on my workstation, but on my work laptop, I somehow magically, for like, it was a month period, I downloaded some cursor,
git push 或 git，甚至写提交信息也很令人困惑，对吧？因为如果你 git add 和 git commit，更改就消失了。然后你会想，发生了什么？你必须去 git log。如果你不去 git log 或 git show，你会有点困惑。它是不是把所有更改都删了？然后你看着文件，你会想，不，更改还在。它是不是去提交了这些？总之，它发生过一次，那是一次非常可怕的经历。如果那不是你。我知道有些人只是让 AI 做所有事情。但我确实喜欢写我自己的非常糟糕的提交信息。它们总是只有两个词或三个词。但这给了我一点乐趣。运行 git add、git commit 和 git push，这是我现在这样做的唯一原因，伙计们。所以很有趣，我在这里走上了一条滑坡。历史上，我写的提交信息是一到两句话，相当描述性，但不是一段话。我通常做的是写代码库的哪个部分发生了变化，比如如果我正在更改我最近一直在处理的教程。所以如果我正在更改一个特定的教程，我会写 tutorials/accelerated Python/笔记本的名字或我正在处理的东西，然后冒号，然后是更改的描述。我有一个 Cursor 规则，基本上说，当你为我写提交信息时，看看之前的提交信息并遵循我使用的格式，并且，你知道，用我的语气陈述它，基本上。遵循我一直在做的风格。我这样做了一段时间，然后从上周开始，我对这个仓库做了很多更改，我开始使用自动运行，你知道，它开始想要遵循那个格式，写第一句话，但你知道 git 提交信息你可以有一句话，然后你可以有一个空行，然后是一个带有更长描述的段落，然后它开始写稍微
and it just had yellow mode. And I was like, I was so fearful that cursor was going to force me to update at some point. But this was back when it was like Claude 3.5. So it's like, you win some, you lose some, right? Like, really what we need is it with 4.5 opus right now, like 3.5 sonnet. it wasn't as great, but still, it was, it was still amazing to not have to hit that button. And except for one time it did write me, like, write the commit message and like push. And I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Like, I was a little bit scared there. I was like, I did not ask you to do that. I do not know why you think I wanted you to do that. And then so I immediately was like, you know, added it to the custom rules or whatever they were called and was like, please never
更长的描述，有一次我当时想，好吧，这个更长的描述实际上很有帮助。我就直接说，好吧，批准。然后发生的事情是，因为我的 Cursor 规则告诉它应该查看提交，而不是……它变得啰嗦了。是的。我没有告诉它我想要什么格式，我告诉它，只看我之前提交的风格。但后来，我以这种方式写了这个提交，然后它就在写我所有的提交信息。所以随着时间的推移，它开始演变，提交信息变得有点长了。现在它完全是在做它自己的事情。老实说，我并没有太关注它写的提交信息描述，因为它们
get push or get, even even writing a commit message like is confusing, right? And like, because if you get ad and get commit, like the changes disappear. And then you're like, what happened? And you have to go get log. And if you don't go get log, then or get show, like, you're a bit confused. Like, did it just yeat all the changes? And then you're looking at the files and you're like, no, the changes are there. And it's like, did it go commit these? Anyways, so it happened once to me and it was a very terrifying experience. If that's not what you are. I know that there's some people that are just, you know, letting the AI do everything. But I do like writing my own very terrible commit messages. They're always just like two words or three words. But it gives me a little bit of joy. running get ad, get commit, and get push, which is the only reason I do it now, folks. So it's funny, I have, I've gone down a slippery slope here. I, historically, the commit messages that I've written have been one to two sentences in fairly descriptive, but not like a paragraph. And I typically what I do is I write like what section of the code base the changes in, like if I'm changing like something I've been working a lot with our tutorials lately. So if I'm changing a particular tutorial, I would put like tutorials slash accelerated Python slash the name of the
通常都很好。我通常不太关心它是否写了好的提交信息。我太忙于审查它的代码，没时间审查它的提交信息。是的。好吧，我的意思是，我说我们像，我只是觉得你称之为极端漂移，基于 AI 模型的提交信息漂移。但我们还没谈过。所以现在让我们，我的意思是，我们正在以相反的顺序做这件事。
notebook or the stuff I'm working on, then colon, and then a description of the change. And I had a cursor rule that basically said, you know, when you, when you write a commit message for me, look at like the previous commit messages and follow the format that I used and like, you know, make it, like state it in my voice, basically. Like follow the style of what I've been doing. And I did that for a while and then like starting last week I've been doing a lot of changes to this repo and I started using the auto run and you know it started like wanting to it would follow that format for the the first sentence but then you know how get mess get commit messages you can have like one sentence and then you can have like a blank line and then like a paragraph with a longer description and then it started like writing like slightly
我们本应该这样做，但，你知道，这就是生活。混乱中带着信息之源。让我们给出我们的，我先来，然后你来，那么更新是什么？我的意思是，其实，在我们做那个之前，我们什么时候做的 AI 高潮？我想是 2025 年 8 月。看看我是否记对了。AI 高潮，第一部分，第二部分是 2025 年 7 月 25 日和 8 月 1 日。所以那是最后一次。我的意思是，显然，它时不时会出现，但我们还没有真正再次深入探讨 AI 高潮。所以我，我的意思是，我可能不会那样称呼它。也许我会。
longer descriptions and like one time I was like all right this longer description is actually like helpful. And I was just like, all right, approve. And then what happened is because my cursor rule told it that it was supposed to look at the commits, instead of... It became verbose. Yeah. Instead of telling it exactly what format I want, I told it, just look at the style of my previous commits. But then, like, I wrote this one commit this way, and then it was writing all my commit messages. So over time, it started to evolve, and the commit messages have gotten a little bit longer. And now it's like, it's totally doing its own thing. And honestly, I don't look that much at the commit message descriptions that it is writing because they've
我不知道。也许我们会重温。我以为你会称它为“点子人”。不，不，不。因为我们要把这个分开。我们把下一个，下一部分，称为“点子人”那一集。所以这一集，我们只是在谈论我们现在的工作流程。所以我回想，其实，让我们去，他们称之为什么？
usually been good. I'm usually not that concerned about whether it's written a good commit message or not. I do like, I'm too busy like reviewing its code to spend time reviewing its commit messages. Yeah. Well, I mean, I said we were like, I was just thinking that you call that like extreme drift, commit message drift based on the AI models. But we haven't actually talked. So let's now like, I mean, we were doing this the reverse order that.
是智能指数吗？人工智能分析是它的名字。我不想恢复浏览。直接带我去网站。其实，我会分享这个。让我移动一些东西。让我们把 Bryce 的头移到这里。现在我要分享，因为我们之前分享过这个网站，但我们也会链接它。
we should have, but, you know, Se la V. Chaos with Springs of Information. Let's give our, I'll go first and then you go, so what is the update? I mean, actually, before we do that, let's, when, when did we do the high on AI? I think it was August of 2025. Let's see if I am correct about that. High on AI, part one, part two was July 25th and August 1st of 2025. So that's the last time. I mean, obviously, it comes up from time to time, but we haven't really done a deep dive being high on AI again. So I'm, I mean, I'm probably not going to call it. Maybe I will.
现在我们要向下滚动到我们想要的是这个。为什么他们默认显示 16 种不同的 LLM，我不知道，伙计们。韩国电信是一个 LLM。我们只关心 Google、Anthropic 和 OpenAI。所以现在我们正盯着，我在 12 月的一次演讲中展示过这个。这是他们引入不同模型时的演变。所以现在我们处于 Gemini 3.1，GPT 5.4，这是最近发布的，还没试过，伙计们，但我通常不喜欢 OpenAI 的模型。然后是 Claude Opus 4.6。所以回到 2025 年 7 月，
I don't know. Maybe we're going to revisit. I thought you were going to call it idea person. No, no, no. Because we're going to split this up. We'll call one of the next one, the next part, the idea person one. So this one, we're just talking about our workflow now. So I think back in, and actually, let's go to the, what do they call it?
我们显然是在 Claude 4，Sonnet，Gemini 2.4.5 和 o3 Pro 上。所以那时我们正在使用 Claude 4，但它是 Sonnet 4。而且有巨大的差异，巨大的差异，伙计们，在他们发布的时候，它并没有真正显示他们什么时候发布的，或者我猜 4.5 实际上是，所以 4 很好。但是的，4.5 是 11 月底的巨大飞跃。所以，你知道，显然我们喜欢这些工具，每天都在使用它们。然后他们发布了 4.5，Claude 4.5，Sonnet 和 Opus，11 月下旬。
Is it intelligence index? Artificial, artificial analysis is what it's called. I don't want to resume browsing. Just bring me to the website. And actually, I'll share this. Let me move some stuff around. let us take Bryce's head, move that over here. And now I'm going to share, because we've shared this site before, but we will link it as well.
实际日期是什么？好吧，它说 Sonnet 是 12 月 28 日，但 Opus 是，是的，11 月 23 日。我记得这个，然后这就像，看看这些有多接近。GPT 5.1，Gemini 3 Pro 和 Claude 4.5 Opus，点字几乎就在彼此上面。所以可能是 OpenAI 先在 12 号发布，然后他们都在几周内发布了模型升级。这就像，这是一个巨大的飞跃。我做的第一件事基本上是为我在 12 月的那次演讲创建了整个幻灯片。我创建了整个幻灯片。我从创建标题幻灯片开始。然后我当时想，哦，也许我会做“关于我”的幻灯片。
And now we are going to scroll down to what we want is this one. Why they show 16 different LLMs by default is beyond me, folks. Korea Telecom is an LLM. And all we care about is Google Anthropic, an open. AI. So right now we are staring at, I've showed this in a talk that I gave back in December. It is the evolution when they introduced the different models. So right now we're on Gemini 3.1, GPT 5.4, which is the most recently released, haven't taken it for a spin, folks, but I typically don't like the open AI models. And then Claude Opus 4.6. So back in July of 2025,
然后我当时想，等一下，我可以一直要求它创建新的幻灯片。它创建了这个 nav.js 的东西。整个事情都是用 JavaScript 完成的。哦，天哪。它太美了。但那并没有发挥它的全部潜力，伙计们。从那以后，你知道，4.6 就在一个月前出来了。我的意思是，4.6。
we clearly were on Claude 4, Sonnet, Gemini 2.4. 5 and 03 Pro. So back then we were using Claude 4, but it was Sonnet 4. And there's a huge difference, huge difference, folks, between when they released, it doesn't really show when they released, or I guess was 4.5 was actually, so 4 was good. But yeah, 4.5 was the huge jump in the tail end of November. So, you know, obviously we love these tools, was using them daily. and then they released 4.5 and Claude 4.5, Sonnet and Opus, late November.
所以事情是这样的，这是大事情之一。我过去每天都使用 Sonnet，因为 Opus 花的时间太长了。你不能那么容易地中断它。我觉得使用 Sonnet，实际上，你可以通过在它偏离你想要的轨道时重定向它来走得更远。现在，模型太好了，你必须使用大的，伙计们。你必须使用大的。它们一次性解决所有问题，效果非常好。然后你显然想以不同的方式设计它，但可能在接下来的点子那一集中，我们将谈论所有不同的事情。
What was the actual date? It was, well, it says Sonnet was December 28th, but then Opus was, yeah, November 23rd. And I remember this, and then this was like, look at how close these were. GPD 5.1, Gemini 3 Pro, and Cloud 4.5 Opus, the dots are literally like on top of each other. So it was probably OpenEI, released first on the 12th, and then they all, within like a couple weeks, drop their model increases. This was like, it was a massive jump. And the first thing that I ended up doing was basically creating my whole slide deck for that talk that I gave in December. I created the whole slide deck. I started by creating the title slide. And then I was like, oh, maybe I'll do the About Me slide.
上一集，我提到可能在一个周末，你可以构建一个播客应用程序。那个播客应用程序已经构建好了。它很美。它比外面所有的其他播客应用程序都好。我一直在使用它。还有几个。哦，是的。所以我会的。好吧，我应该吗？也许我会，如果伙计们在 GitHub 讨论中留下评论，我会想办法给人们 APK 的访问权限。我还没发布它。我希望这个东西是完美的。或者至少对于我的日常用例来说是完美的。显然，会有一些我没遇到的边缘情况，因为那不是我使用播客应用程序的方式。但仍然，我使用这个。所以在我分享给 Bryce 之前，我添加了一个统计页面。那是上周五。所以我们在周二早上录制这个。从那时起，我已经听了 20 集。集，14 小时 25 分钟，它有漂亮的统计数据。但每天，我都会注意到一些事情，比如今天早上，我醒来，我的播客不在那里。这是一个其他播客应用程序的常见问题。我想 Apple Podcasts 可能没有这个问题，但因为它需要后台检查是否有新的更新，许多手机为了节省电池，会
And then I was like, wait a second, I can just keep on asking it to create a new slide. It created this nav.js thing. The whole thing was done in JavaScript. Oh, my God. It was beautiful. But that was not taking it to its full potential, folks. And since then, you know, 4.6 came out like just a month ago. And I mean, 4.6.
积极地关闭应用程序在你不主动使用该应用程序时执行不同操作的能力。奇怪的是，当我打开它时，里面应该有一些代码说，哦，你已经打开了应用程序，一定要去检查一下，但我不得不去关闭应用程序，重新打开应用程序。然后三个新播客中只有一个在那时下载了。
And so the thing is, here's one of the big things. I used to use Sonnet on a daily basis because Opus took too long. You couldn't interrupt it as easily. And I felt that working with Sonnet, actually, you could get further by, like, redirecting it whenever it went off the, you know, the railway that you wanted. it to go down. Now, the models are so good, you got to use the big ones, folks. You got to use the big ones. They one shot everything so well. And then you obviously want to design it a little bit differently, but probably up next in the idea episode, we're going to talk about all the different things.
我不得不手动去。所以还有一些小 bug。98% 的时间，它工作得非常完美。而且它比我之前使用的 CastBox 和其他应用程序工作得更好，只是因为我按照我想要使用它的方式设计了它。总之，我们要谈谈那个。我们要谈谈 Array Box。
Last episode, I mentioned probably in a weekend, on a weekend day, you could build a podcast app. That podcast app has been built. It is beautiful. It's better than all the other podcast apps out there. I've been using it. There's still a few. Oh, yeah. So I will. well, should I? Maybe I will give, if folks leave comments on the GitHub discussion, I will find a way to give people access to the APK. I'm not releasing it yet. I want this thing to be perfect. Or at least perfect for my daily use cases. Obviously, there's going to be edge cases that I don't run into because it's not the way that I use podcasting apps. But still, like, I use this. So I added right before I shared it with Bryce, I added a stats page. And that was last Friday. So recording this on Tuesday morning. Since then, I've listened to 20 episodes. episodes, 14 hours and 25 minutes, and it's got beautiful stats. But every day, I noticed something like this morning, I woke up, my podcasts were not there. And this is a common issue for other podcast apps. I imagine Apple Podcasts doesn't have this, but because it requires background, like, checking of is there new updates, a lot of phones in order to conserve battery will, like,
你确实给了我仓库的访问权限，对吧？我周末希望提交一些问题并修复一些东西，但我没时间。我没加你，但现在有两个不同的仓库。其中一个是公开的，所以我只是说把它们提交到那个上面。那个是支持 Podgod.ca 网站的仓库。还有一个是私有的，我可能会暂时保持私有，因为我认为这实际上可能会火起来，因为它将成为播客听众的播客播放器。
aggressively shut down apps' abilities to, like, do different things. while you're not using that app actively. The weird thing is, is when I opened it, there's supposed to be some code in there that says, oh, you've opened the app, definitely go and do a check, but I had to go shut down the app, reopen the app. And then only one of the three new podcasts had downloaded at that point.
所有这些其他播客都不是为听众准备的。因此，这些公司试图赚钱。CastBox，我之前使用的那个，是一家 VC 支持的播客公司，一直在用广告轰炸你。这就是为什么当你看着艺术品时，它总是在广告和剧集的实际艺术品之间旋转。当你多次在剧集和下载之间切换时，它会向你展示一个你必须跳过的 30 秒广告。然后他们有他们的付费功能，也就是付钱。猜猜怎么着，伙计们，我不想靠这个赚钱。我的意思是，别误会。
I had to go manually. So there's still little bugs. 98% of the time, it works perfectly. And it works better than CastBox, which I was using before and other ones, just because I designed it the way I want to use it. Anyways, we're going to talk about that. We'll talk about Array Box.
我很乐意靠这个赚钱。但我不是，就像 ADSP 从来没有广告一样。我不会说我们永远不会有广告。如果有改变生活的钱，我很乐意卖掉，伙计们。我很乐意卖掉它。你告诉我一个数字。我会让你知道那个数字是否足够大。但是，你知道，我不认为有人会给我一个数字，让我会觉得，
You did give me access to the repo, right? I was hoping over the weekend to file some issues and fix some things, but I didn't have time. I didn't add you, but there's two different repos right now. One of them is a public one, so I just said file them on that. That is the one that backs the Podgod.ca website. There's another one that's privated, which I'm probably going to keep privated for now, because I think that this could actually like take off, because it is going to be a podcast player for podcast listeners.
我会让我们的数千名听众看广告。因为我个人讨厌广告。这是我前几天遇到的另一个问题。我试图从锁屏跳过广告，我不小心按到了进度条的末尾。当我的播客达到 100% 时，它们会自动被删除。那非常不幸。但后来我做了什么？
All these other podcasts are not for listeners. Therefore, these companies that are trying to make money. CastBox, the one that I was using, is a VC-backed podcast like company that is like spamming you with ads all the times. That's why when you're looking at the artwork, it's always like rotating in between an ad and between the actual artwork of the episode. And like when you go in between episodes and downloads enough times, it shows you like a 30 second ad that you have to like, you know, skip. And then they've got their premium thing, which is like pay money. Guess what, folks, I don't want to make money off of this. I mean, don't get me wrong.
我只是去阻止了那个能力。比如，你多久会在播客的锁屏上使用进度条来跳过？你从来不会那样做。是的。你试图跳过的唯一时间是当你试图跳过广告时，你使用那个小小的跳过 30 秒，跳过 30 秒。总之，我们谈论 Podgod 太多了。
I'd be happy to make money off of this. But I'm not the same way that ADSP has never had an ad. I'm not going to say we never will have an ad. If there's a life-changing amount of money, I'm happy to sell out, folks. I'm happy to sell it. You tell me a number. And I'll let you know if that number is big enough. But, you know, I don't think anyone's going to give me a number that I'm going to be like,
但重点是，Claude 4.6 Opus，它基本上是我每天使用的驱动程序。它太棒了。如果你还没试过，你一定要去试一下。每隔一段时间，如果我给它太难的任务，因为我现在把世界都交给它了。它会失败。几分钟后，如果我不能让它得到正确的答案，我就进入多模式，或者多代理模式，我会给 Gemini 3.1，你知道，5.3 codex，或者我现在猜是 5.4 codex。然后，你知道，Sonnet 和 Opus。无论你什么时候这样做，它们中总有一个能解决问题。这就是我目前的状况。你的日常工作流程是什么？我们知道你在用 Cursor。你用的是什么模型？我想我，好吧，我刚才在检查。
I'll subject the thousands of listeners that we have to an ad. Because I personally hate ads. That's one of the other issues I ran into the other day. I was trying to skip an ad from the lock screen, and I accidentally hit, like, the tracker to the end. And when my podcast hit 100%, they automatically get deleted. And that was very unfortunate. But then what did I do?
我用的是 Claude 4.6 Opus 高级思维模式。我用的是那种最慢、最好的模型，因为我不在乎需要多长时间。我希望它尽可能好。而且我不用付账单。所以，你知道，我把它用于工作，用于工作的事情，他们没告诉我担心成本。所以我只是用最顶级的那个，我想 4.6 Opus 是带有高级思维的顶级模型。这是你也在用的吗，大概？我相信是。
I just went and blocked the ability. Like, how often do you ever use the tracker, like the slider, on the lock screen of a podcast in order to skip ahead? You never do that. Yeah. The only time you're trying to skip ahead is when you're trying to skip ads, and you use the little skip 30, skip 30. Anyways, we're talking too much about podgod.
我直接禁用了这个功能。话说回来，你在播客锁屏界面上用那个进度条滑块来快进的频率有多高？你根本不会那样做。没错。你唯一想快进的时候就是为了跳过广告，而你通常会用那个“跳过30秒”的小按钮。总之，我们关于Podgod聊得太多了。
But the point is, quad 4.6 opus, it's basically what I use as my daily driver. It's amazing. You have to go try it if you haven't tried it. Every once in a while, if I give it too difficult to task, because I am giving it the world now. It will fail. And after like a couple minutes, if I can't get it to, you know, get the right answer, I just go into multi mode where, or multi-agent mode, where I'll give a Gemini 3.1, you know, 5.3 codex or I guess 5.4 codex now. and then, you know, sonnet and opus. And whenever you do that, one of them always solves it. And so that's where I'm at. What is your daily workflow? We know you're on cursor. What's your model that you use? I think I, well, I was just checking.
但重点是，Claude 3.5 Sonnet（注：原文为quad 4.6 opus，此处按语境意译）基本上是我日常主力使用的模型。它太棒了。如果你还没试过，一定要去试试。偶尔如果我给它布置的任务太难，因为它现在要处理各种复杂任务，它也会失败。几分钟后，如果它还是给不出正确答案，我就切换到多模型模式，或者多智能体模式，我会同时调用Gemini 3.1、5.3 Codex（或者现在应该是5.4 Codex了），还有Sonnet和Opus。只要这样做，总有一个能解决问题。这就是我目前的状态。你的日常工作流是怎样的？我们知道你在用Cursor。你用的是什么模型？我想我，嗯，我刚才正在检查。
I use the Claude 4.6 opus high thinking. I use like the slowest, like, best thing because I don't care how long it takes. I want it to be as good as possible. and I am not paying the bill. So, you know, I'm using it for work, for work stuff, and they didn't tell me to worry about the cost. So I just use whatever the top thing, which I think 4.6 opus is the top thing with the high thinking. Is that what you're using too, presumably? I believe so.
我用的是Claude 3.5 Sonnet（注：原文为Claude 4.6 opus，此处按语境意译）的高级思考模式。我用的是那种最慢、最强的模型，因为我不在乎它花多长时间。我只想要最好的结果。而且账单又不是我付，所以，你知道，我是为了工作使用它，公司也没让我担心成本问题。所以我直接用最顶级的模型，我想Claude 3.5 Sonnet的高级思考模式就是目前最顶级的。你用的也是这个吗？应该是吧。
I've gone to cursor dashboard, which they definitely at one point used to tell you, I mean, there is a usage thing, but the usage. just shows you the cost of every single request that you make. And if I went, I went down to, I clicked on the left on analytics and it showed it there. It showed, when it showed my like ranking, it showed me what was the most common, the model I used most commonly. And see, mine shows me the activity graph. I mean, you're looking at my screen right now, scroll down, scroll down to the bottom. Yeah, you see right there, it should say opus high. So you're not using thinking mode as frequently.
我去了Cursor的仪表板，他们肯定在某个时候会告诉你，我的意思是，有一个使用情况统计，但那个使用情况只是向你展示你发出的每一个请求的成本。我点击了左侧的分析，它就显示在那里。它显示了我的排名，还显示了我最常用的模型。你看，我的显示了活动图表。我的意思是，你现在正在看我的屏幕，向下滚动，滚动到底部。是的，你就在那里看到了，它应该显示Opus high。所以你没有那么频繁地使用思考模式。
Where does it, wait, where does it say open-eye? You see in the list of rankings, it shows where you are in the rankings. Oh, yeah, yeah. That's sad, though. They used to actually give you like a pie chart. Yeah, I mean, I do it mostly for, actually, I don't know why. I probably just clicked it. And maybe actually, I think I have switched back and forth because thinking does have, well, I don't actually know.
它在哪里，等等，它在哪里显示Opus？你看排名列表，它显示了你在排名中的位置。哦，是的，是的。不过那很遗憾。他们过去确实会给你一个饼图之类的东西。是的，我的意思是，我主要这样做是因为，其实我不知道为什么。我可能只是点击了它。也许实际上，我想我已经来回切换过了，因为思考模式确实有，嗯，我其实不知道。
I think, well, that's why I want to see a pie chart because, yeah, I'm not sure. I'm not sure why I'm not using the thinking. Maybe I would have, those couple problems that I had, thinking would have fixed it for me. I never really changed the model. I just always used thinking. And I don't even, like, I haven't even, like, I don't even play around with other models that much. I'm mostly just, like, I'm too busy for that.
我想，嗯，这就是为什么我想看饼图，因为，是的，我不确定。我不确定为什么我没有使用思考模式。也许我本来会，我遇到的那几个问题，思考模式本来可以帮我解决的。我从来没有真正改变过模型。我总是使用思考模式。我甚至，就像，我甚至没有，我甚至没有怎么玩过其他模型。我大部分时间只是，就像，我太忙了，没空做那个。
I'm too busy for that shit. I got too much stuff to do. But yeah, I always, I always just use the one that's, like, slowest and fastest. I mean, what I do is, have you started using the Git Work trees? Yeah, I mean, that's easy. You just click a button and it sets it up. And then you need that for the multi-agent mode. Yeah.
我太忙了，没空搞那些。我有太多事情要做。但是是的，我总是，我总是只使用那个，就像，最慢和最快的。我的意思是，我做的是，你开始使用Git工作树了吗？是的，我的意思是，那很简单。你只需点击一个按钮，它就会设置好。然后你需要那个来进行多智能体模式。是的。
So I don't, so the multi-agent mode is the one where, like, you have it, like, multiple agents working on different solutions to the same problem. And then, like, it shows you the best one. I haven't used that. I mean, maybe I could try using that. But my primary, like, mode of operation is to, like, be working in parallel. So I'll typically have two or three different, you know, tasks than I'm working on at a time. So I'll have two to three different chat windows open. Sometimes, sometimes four, but usually it's two to three because, like, that's roughly the, like, length of the pipeline of, you know, I write, I write some prompt of, here's the next thing to go do, and then when it starts churning on that, I go to the next window and I start feeding the
所以我没有，所以多智能体模式是那种，就像，你让它，就像，多个智能体针对同一个问题研究不同的解决方案。然后，就像，它向你展示最好的一个。我没有用过那个。我的意思是，也许我可以尝试使用它。但我的主要，就像，操作模式是，就像，并行工作。所以我通常会同时进行两到三个不同的，你知道，任务。所以我会有两到三个不同的聊天窗口打开。有时，有时四个，但通常是两到三个，因为，就像，那大致是，就像，流水线的长度，你知道，我写，我写一些提示词说，这是接下来要做的事情，然后当它开始处理那个时，我就去下一个窗口，开始输入
next prompt in, and then I sort of like ping pong back and forth. And I found that like two to three is about the number of like tasks that I can have running concurrently because like it needs my attention at some points, right? Like it either needs my attention to approve something or it needs my attention because it's finished, its response, and it needs more input from me. And I use, I'll typically use the get work trees. I have run into a couple issues with the get work trees. But then the other thing is I try to, I try to find separable tasks, tasks that are not going to have overlap within the code base. And that's actually challenging because I think typically when you're working on one thing, you'll realize that something else
下一个提示词，然后我就像乒乓球一样来回切换。我发现两到三个大约是我可以同时运行的任务数量，因为，就像，它在某些时候需要我的注意，对吧？就像它要么需要我的注意来批准某事，要么因为它完成了，它的响应，需要我更多的输入。我使用，我通常会使用Git工作树。我确实遇到过几个关于Git工作树的问题。但另一件事是，我尝试，我尝试寻找可分离的任务，那些在代码库中不会有重叠的任务。这实际上很有挑战性，因为我认为通常当你处理一件事时，你会意识到其他事情
has to be done in the same place in the code. But if it's, you don't want to see realize your process. And so if I'm working on like one file, let's say, and I realize some other change needs to be made within that file to like the same place that the current, you know, chat, the current agent is working in. If I go and have in a separate work tree, another agent work on that related task on the related code, then I'm going to probably end up with some sort of merge conflict later. And sure, it can resolve the merge conflict. But if I end up with a ton of merge conflicts, like it takes it time to go and resolve the merge conflicts, sometimes like more time than like other tasks. And so I typically want to avoid that. And so I try to find
必须在代码的同一个地方完成。但如果它是，你不想意识到你的过程。所以如果我正在处理一个文件，比方说，我意识到在该文件中需要对同一个地方进行其他更改，即当前的，你知道，聊天，当前的智能体正在工作的地方。如果我去并在一个单独的工作树中，让另一个智能体处理那个相关任务的相关代码，那么我可能会在以后遇到某种合并冲突。当然，它可以解决合并冲突。但如果我最终遇到大量的合并冲突，就像它需要时间去解决合并冲突，有时比其他任务花费的时间更多。所以我通常想避免这种情况。所以我尝试寻找
like separate places in the code base where I can be working like two completely separate tasks or at the same time. And then what I do is like if I am working in one place and I realize, oh, hey, there's this other thing that I need to do, I will buffer up that other task in some way. I feel more like a project manager because I have like these, you know, lists of like to-do items or of like action items or GitHub issues or things that need to be done that I keep in various places. I was thinking about like filing a GitHub issue for each thing. But honestly, like that would be too time consuming. That would be too, that would be too process heavy. So what I...
就像代码库中分开的地方，我可以像同时处理两个完全独立的任务一样工作。然后我做的是，如果我正在一个地方工作，我意识到，哦，嘿，还有另一件事我需要做，我会以某种方式缓冲那个任务。我感觉更像一个项目经理，因为我有像这些，你知道，待办事项列表，或者行动项目，或者GitHub问题，或者需要完成的事情，我把它们保存在不同的地方。我曾想过为每件事提交一个GitHub问题。但老实说，那太耗时了。那会太，那会太流程繁重了。所以我就...
It is so funny that you say that because like I used to. That was my workflow. Anytime I would have a project and, you know, I'd encounter something that either needed. to be fixed or changed or a feature that I wanted to add. I'd go. Usually I have like, what do you call it? Like a plan to do list. And then I would create sub-issues that would all link because it looks nice and whenever you finish one and they turn purple on GitHub. And now I don't, I don't create those anymore. I just have a to-do like text file. And then I just, I put them in because you can finish them so quickly. And one time, I looked at the list and I was like,
你说那话太搞笑了，因为，就像我曾经那样。那是我的工作流程。每当我有项目，并且，你知道，我遇到需要修复或更改的事情，或者我想添加的功能。我会去。通常我有，你叫它什么？就像一个计划待办事项列表。然后我会创建子问题，它们都会链接起来，因为它看起来不错，每当你完成一个，它们在GitHub上就会变成紫色。现在我不，我不创建那些了。我只有一个待办事项文本文件。然后我就，我把它们放进去，因为你可以很快地完成它们。有一次，我看着列表，我就想，
actually, you know what? I just pointed Opus 4.6 at it and said, there's my to-do list. I was in plan mode and I said make a plan to like do all these things. And as long as they're not like too big of tasks, it'll then go and create like a really nice like checkbox, checkbox, checkbox. It'll do them one at a time. And like, I remember one time I had like 14 things in a to do list, which like typically I would have gone and created 14 different issues and then closed them one at a time. And it just got, I think it got 13 out of 14 them like one shoted. And you know, you have to go and test them and verify that it did it. But I was just like, so it's so funny that you're saying you used to use issues and now you just use like a to do
其实，你知道吗？我只是把Opus 4.6指向它，说，这是我的待办事项列表。我处于计划模式，我说制定一个计划来做所有这些事情。只要它们不是太大的任务，它就会去创建像一个非常好的复选框，复选框，复选框。它会一个接一个地做。而且，就像，我记得有一次我的待办事项列表里有14件事，通常我会去创建14个不同的问题，然后一个接一个地关闭它们。它就，我想它一次性搞定了14个中的13个。而且，你知道，你必须去测试它们并验证它是否做到了。但我当时就想，所以你说你过去使用问题，现在只使用待办事项列表，这太搞笑了，
list because that's exactly what I've started realizing too. It's a waste of time to go set these things up because you can basically fix them and add features so quickly. So you said 14. That's cute. That's cute. Now, admittedly, this is out of line in the repo because this is on a project that I'm working with other people on. And so I needed to share it with them and we use a lot of Google docs within Nvidia, although there are now very good tools for hooking up Google Docs to agents. But this is my list of things. And I don't know. How many items do you think are here? I mean, there's like 10 pages, so we're going to go definitely in the hundreds.
因为那正是我也开始意识到的。去设置这些东西是浪费时间，因为你基本上可以很快地修复它们并添加功能。所以你说14个。那很可爱。那很可爱。现在，诚然，这在仓库里是不合规的，因为这是在一个我和其他人一起工作的项目上。所以我需要和他们分享，我们在Nvidia内部使用很多Google文档，尽管现在有很好的工具可以将Google文档连接到智能体。但这是我的事情列表。我不知道。你认为这里有多少项？我的意思是，大约有10页，所以我们肯定会达到几百个。
Yeah. So admittedly, this is like a backlog from, like, originally this was like in my personal to-do list from like the last like four or five months of like all the various stuff I'd written down. This is for our training material. And basically every time I do the training, I make a bunch of notes of like, we need to fix this, fix this, fix this. And I write it down.
是的。所以诚然，这就像一个积压工作，从，最初这就像在我过去四五个月的个人待办事项列表中，记录了我写下的所有各种各样的东西。这是为了我们的培训材料。基本上每次我做培训时，我都会做一堆笔记，比如，我们需要修复这个，修复这个，修复这个。然后我把它写下来。
And then like last week, I just like took them all and I merged them and organized. them a bit. But just like this set of things right here that's undercompleted, this is, I don't know, this is maybe, maybe 40 items. And like each one is like basically a sentence or so. Some of them are like descriptive sentences that say exactly what the change should be. And then like why. Some of them are just like, you know, like kernel correctness checks. But these are like 40 things, 40 like individual things. And these are all things that I fixed in like the last two days. and this is not even like all the things that I actually fixed because there's some set of things that I notice while I'm doing other things and I just queue it up in in cursor itself. One of the nice thing is with the cursor chat, if it's working on a prompt, you can send a follow up.
然后就像上周，我只是把它们全部拿来，我合并并整理了一下。但就像这里这一组在“已完成”下的东西，这是，我不知道，这也许，也许有40项。而且每一项基本上就是一句话左右。有些是描述性的句子，准确说明了应该进行的更改。然后是为什么。有些只是，你知道，像内核正确性检查。但这些是40件事，40个独立的事情。这些都是我在过去两天里修复的事情。而且这甚至不是我实际修复的所有事情，因为有些事情是我在做其他事情时注意到的，我就直接在Cursor本身中排队了。其中一个好处是使用Cursor聊天，如果它正在处理一个提示词，你可以发送一个后续。
And the way that it works is it has a cue. And so by default, if you type something while it's working on something, you press enter, it doesn't send it to the agent immediately by default. it puts it into this little queue, and then once the agent has finished its current prompt, then it will send whatever the next thing is in the queue in the same chat session. But there is also a button for it called Send Now. So you can press that, and that will send the message immediately. And so if you're watching what it's doing and you see in its thinking trace that it's like going off in the wrong direction, you can send a message to it immediately like saying, you know, oh, don't do that.
它的工作方式是它有一个队列。所以默认情况下，如果你在它处理某事时输入内容，你按回车，默认情况下它不会立即发送给智能体。它把它放入这个小队列中，然后一旦智能体完成了它当前的提示词，它就会在同一个聊天会话中发送队列中的下一件事。但也有一个按钮叫“立即发送”。所以你可以按那个，那会立即发送消息。所以如果你正在观察它在做什么，并且你在它的思考轨迹中看到它像是在朝着错误的方向发展，你可以立即给它发送一条消息，说，你知道，哦，别那样做。
And I do do that, you know, every now and then where I'm like, oh, you're heading in the wrong direction. Like, don't do that, do this instead. But what I will often do is, as I said before, like, you know, sometimes you'll be working on a project or working on one particular task. And then you notice that there's something else related, like, in the same place. And so what I'll often do is if I notice that while it's working on something, I'll just put the follow-up thing in the same chat and I'll cue up a couple of them. And like those, I don't even, I don't even write down those to-do. I've just like, I've queued up,
我确实会那样做，你知道，每隔一段时间，我就会说，哦，你正朝着错误的方向前进。就像，别那样做，做这个代替。但我经常做的是，正如我之前所说，就像，你知道，有时你会处理一个项目或处理一个特定的任务。然后你注意到有其他相关的事情，就像，在同一个地方。所以我经常做的是，如果我在它处理某事时注意到这一点，我就会把后续的事情放在同一个聊天中，我会排队几个。而且就像那些，我甚至不，我甚至不写下那些待办事项。我只是，就像，我已经排队了，
I've queued up this series of prompts that are going out to the agent. I, I am a little cautious about doing that because I don't want to like, you know, I don't want to have one chat context that has like a bunch of unrelated tasks, but I do find myself,
我已经排队了这一系列发送给智能体的提示词。我，我对此有点谨慎，因为我不想，你知道，我不想有一个包含一堆不相关任务的聊天上下文，但我确实发现自己，
like in the early days, like when I start first started using cursor last year, and I guess it was like spring last year, maybe. Maybe it was earlier than that. I noticed, I would very frequently create a new chat because as the chats got longer, performance of cursor itself got worse, but also I found that it went off on more tangents. So I would almost always, for a new task, I would
就像在早期，就像去年我刚开始使用Cursor时，我想那是去年春天，也许。也许比那更早。我注意到，我会非常频繁地创建一个新聊天，因为随着聊天变得越来越长，Cursor本身的性能变差了，而且我也发现它更容易跑题。所以我几乎总是，对于一个新任务，我会
start a new chat. I think mostly because of this problem where I had a long time where cursors, UI, like in the early days would like freeze up for me all the time. But now what I find myself doing is I'm more likely to continue work in an existing chat because usually the, you know, There's like relevant context there. Like I've told it to do, you know, like, I've told it to like do some task and I want to tell it to like extend or or fix something like related to like some function foo or some feature X. And if I was in a new chat, I could probably just say something vague like, you know, like, sorry, if I'm in a new chat, I can't say something vague. If I'm in a new chat, I can't tell it just like, oh, go add, like, go at, let me give a better example. Let's say that I'm like modifying some function to add a new parameter to the function.
开始一个新的聊天。我想主要是因为这个问题，我有一段时间Cursor的UI，就像在早期，总是会为我冻结。但现在我发现自己做的是，我更有可能在现有的聊天中继续工作，因为通常，你知道，那里有相关的上下文。就像我已经告诉它做，你知道，就像，我已经告诉它做某个任务，我想告诉它扩展或修复一些与某个函数foo或某个功能X相关的东西。如果我在一个新的聊天中，我可能只能说一些模糊的话，比如，你知道，就像，抱歉，如果我在一个新的聊天中，我不能说一些模糊的话。如果我在一个新的聊天中，我不能告诉它只是，哦，去添加，就像，去添加，让我举个更好的例子。假设我正在修改某个函数以向该函数添加一个新参数。
And so I modify it in one place. And then I'm like, you know what, there's this other function that I should also add the same parameter to. If I do that in a new chat, then I have to tell it, go add a parameter to function fu, just like this parameter that was added to function bar. But if I do it in the existing chat, I can just tell it, go add the same thing to bar. I don't have to, like, explain more. I can type it out quicker. I don't have to give it as much context.
所以我在一个地方修改它。然后我就想，你知道吗，还有另一个函数我也应该添加相同的参数。如果我在一个新的聊天中这样做，那么我必须告诉它，去给函数fu添加一个参数，就像给函数bar添加的这个参数一样。但如果我在现有的聊天中这样做，我可以直接告诉它，去给bar添加同样的东西。我不必，就像，解释更多。我可以更快地打出来。我不必给它那么多上下文。
So I find myself doing that more and more, and I've had less issues with it getting confused with large contexts. Yeah, degradation is not as big a deal. And I found it's, yeah, it's funny. I think probably a lot of people that use these tools on the daily end up learning the same things because I have the exact same thing. like unless if it's an entirely new like thing that is going to require a long conversation, I almost always just keep it in the same chat because there's always at least like 10% of what you were just doing.
所以我发现自己越来越多地这样做，而且我遇到的关于它因大上下文而感到困惑的问题也更少了。是的，退化不是什么大问题。我发现它是，是的，这很有趣。我想可能很多每天使用这些工具的人最终都会学到同样的东西，因为我有完全相同的情况。就像除非是一个全新的需要长时间对话的事情，我几乎总是把它保留在同一个聊天中，因为总是有至少10%是你刚才正在做的事情。
Even if it's just like for me, because I've been working on like the podcast player, like building the release APK and launching the emulator, like that is in the build thing. But like as soon as you have like a chat window open, you've done it once, like it's like so fast. Like, whereas anytime you open a new chat, you're going to see it go and, like, read the docs and figure out how to do it again. And, like, even that much, it's just like the model, like these, the conversation lengths don't lead to degradation the way that they used to. So what's the point in starting a new one?
即使只是像对我来说，因为我一直在处理像播客播放器，比如构建发布APK和启动模拟器，就像那是在构建的东西里。但就像一旦你打开了一个聊天窗口，你做过一次，就像它非常快。就像，而每当你打开一个新的聊天，你会看到它去，就像，阅读文档并再次弄清楚如何做。而且，就像，即使是那样，它也只是像模型，就像这些，对话长度不会像过去那样导致退化。所以开始一个新的有什么意义呢？
And unless if there's some, like, good reason. There is, there is a disadvantage, which is I have found that for cursor rules that are set to always apply, which is most of my cursor rules, because most of my cursor rules are very short. So if you have a long cursor rule, then you want to have a cursor rule where you have this little header where you tell it, like, in what situations does this apply? If you've got one that's like a big, long, descriptive thing. But a lot of my cursor rules are very short. Like my cursor rule for the commit messages is just like when you commit a Git, when you make a Git commit, look at the existing Git commits to understand the, you know, format and style used in this repo. It's literally one
除非有什么，就像，充分的理由。有一个，有一个缺点，就是我发现对于设置为始终应用的Cursor规则，这是我大部分的Cursor规则，因为我大部分的Cursor规则都很短。所以如果你有一个长的Cursor规则，那么你想要有一个Cursor规则，你有一个小标题，你告诉它，就像，这种情况适用于什么情况？如果你有一个像大而长的描述性东西。但我的很多Cursor规则都很短。就像我关于提交信息的Cursor规则只是像当你提交Git时，当你进行Git提交时，查看现有的Git提交以了解此仓库中使用的格式和风格。它字面上只有一
sentence. So there's no point in me having a like short description of that at the top. So I just said it to be an always apply rule. And what I've found at least maybe this was more true like two or three weeks ago before the latest cursor updates. But in longer chats, it would not look at the cursor rule or like it would just completely ignore the cursor rules. And what I think was happening is for the always apply rules, like it had them, it reads them in its like initial prompt. It gets included in the initial prompt, but then, like, if I had a long chat, like, the cursor rule was falling out of the context. I've noticed less of that recently, but I also, like, the main cursor rule that I had
句话。所以我没有必要在顶部有一个像那样的简短描述。所以我只是把它设置为始终应用的规则。我发现至少也许这在两三周前，在最新的Cursor更新之前更真实。但在更长的聊天中，它不会查看Cursor规则，或者就像它会完全忽略Cursor规则。我认为发生的事情是对于始终应用的规则，就像它拥有它们，它在它的初始提示词中读取它们。它被包含在初始提示词中，但然后，就像，如果我有一个很长的聊天，就像，Cursor规则正在脱离上下文。我最近注意到这种情况少了，但我也，就像，我拥有的主要Cursor规则
was the get-commit message one. I don't know that I have any other, like, cursor rules that are super impactful. I know everybody, like, talks a lot about skills and cursor roles and stuff like that. Honestly, maybe I'm doing something wrong, but I have not found. as much of a need for that recently. Maybe it's just been the sort of task that I've been doing, but even with no rules, the reason why I would think you would need a rule or a skill would be if you're having to explain something multiple times to the model. If like you tell it to do something and it's like doing it wrong and so you have to tell it to do it in a more descriptive way. Like,
是Git提交信息的那一个。我不知道我是否有任何其他，就像，超级有影响力的Cursor规则。我知道每个人，就像，谈论很多关于技能和Cursor角色之类的事情。老实说，也许我做错了什么，但我没有发现。最近对那个的需求那么大。也许只是我一直在做的任务类型，但即使没有规则，我认为你需要规则或技能的原因是如果你必须向模型多次解释某事。如果就像你告诉它做某事，而它做错了，所以你必须以更具描述性的方式告诉它做。就像，
it used to be that whenever I would tell it to make a Git commit, you know, it would write a message that I didn't like. Or one another example, it used to be that if I would tell it to push a commit, I like to have my branches on the main repo, not on my fork. So if I would tell it to, you know, commit this change and push it and open a PR, it would push it to my forked repo instead of to origin, which would drive me nuts, a variety of reasons we can get into some other time. But that would be something that I would create a cursor rule for so that I don't have to explain every time that I wanted to push to origin in not to, you know, my forked repo. I wanted to push to the main repo, the branch to the main repo.
过去每当我告诉它进行Git提交时，你知道，它会写一条我不喜欢的消息。或者另一个例子，过去如果我告诉它推送一个提交，我喜欢把我的分支放在主仓库上，而不是我的分支上。所以如果我告诉它，你知道，提交这个更改并推送它并打开一个PR，它会把它推送到我的分支仓库而不是origin，这会让我发疯，各种原因我们可以在其他时间讨论。但那将是我会为其创建Cursor规则的东西，这样我就不必每次都解释我想推送到origin而不是，你知道，我的分支仓库。我想推送到主仓库，分支到主仓库。
But I have not found that many things, that many things that I'm asking it to do where I need to explain to it how to do that thing in some way that I find myself repeating a lot. I typically, I write some description. Honestly, my prompts are not very good. Sometimes I can write something very vague. and that's usually good enough. Like, I don't find myself spending a lot of time writing cursor rules or skills or anything like that.
但我没有发现那么多事情，那么多我要求它做的事情，我需要以某种方式向它解释如何做那件事，我发现自己重复了很多。我通常，我写一些描述。老实说，我的提示词不是很好。有时我可以写一些非常模糊的东西。而且这通常足够好了。就像，我没有发现自己花很多时间写Cursor规则或技能之类的东西。
Like, I don't, I haven't felt the need for it. Yeah, I have zero cursor rules as of today. I mean, there should be probably one, which would be anytime you're using Python, activate the local UVVM. I do have that one, yeah. Because I constantly am typing that. But I don't know. I like my zero cursor rule workflow because half the time now the VM that I want is actually in some other folder because like it used to be painful if you're in a current repo to like navigate over somewhere else where I've installed a bunch of, you know, multi-gigabytes, you know, Kuta modules from Python.
就像，我没有，我没有感觉到那种需求。是的，截至今天我有零个Cursor规则。我的意思是，应该有一个，那就是每当你使用Python时，激活本地UVVM。我确实有那个，是的。因为我一直在输入那个。但我不知道。我喜欢我的零Cursor规则工作流程，因为现在有一半的时间我想要的VM实际上在其他文件夹中，因为就像过去如果你在一个当前的仓库中，导航到我安装了一堆，你知道，多千兆字节，你知道，来自Python的Kuta模块的其他地方是很痛苦的。
But now I'll just be like, go like go get the VM from that folder and it takes, you know, the time it takes to to type that folder, right? And most of them are just like sitting in home, right? So it's just tilda slash the name of that folder. I don't have to do all the CDing, you know, source dot, activate, whatever the command is. And that's the funny thing, too, is, you know, I hear, maybe we should, because we're at the 46 minute. Let's end of episode one, start of episode two. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
但现在我只会说，去，就像去从那个文件夹获取VM，它花费，你知道，输入那个文件夹的时间，对吧？而且它们大多数只是像坐在home里，对吧？所以它只是波浪号斜杠那个文件夹的名字。我不必做所有的CD，你知道，source dot，激活，无论命令是什么。而且那也是有趣的事情，你知道，我听说，也许我们应该，因为我们已经46分钟了。让我们结束第一集，开始第二集。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening. we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。